how convinced are you that this was an  inside job I don't want to use the  insight  I'm reading this go ahead how can I I  want to know how convinced you are we  know  that the Twin Towers in building seven  were blown up okay we and now narrative  is a lot explosive demolition shaped  cutter charges in the case of of each of  the buildings  are you that 911 was an inside job I  just want to be very clear the question  we have to ask to answer that is did Al  Qaeda have access to three of the most  highly secure buildings outside the  Pentagon probably not that leaves most  of us very convinced that this was an  inside job with security like securicom  stratasec involved up until the day of 9  11. you're a hundred percent you're 90  you're 80 how can 100 you're 100 there  is no doubt